it was a week of beautiful engagements
heart-melting reunions it's gonna fly in
from your face you're trying to bat it
away right and some possible GD lies
it's the bachelor in paradise finale and
it's time for roses and roses a so much
content you guys I'm Lauren Zima and oh
my god guys this finale was crazy what
was the most shocking moment for you
what blew you away the most this season
is the content train that hasn't stopped
and it's just gonna keep rolling on by
of course I'm talking about the fact
that we had a wonderful Monday and
Tuesday night fantasy suite tell all
filled finale episodes set but it was
overshadowed slash bolstered / we were
confused by the real news which is some
rumors about some one of our favorite
members of one of our favorite couples
cheating on that other couples so I'm
talking about Jordan and Jenna it's a
rumor we're gonna dive into it holy crap
let's go okay it's Monday night's
episode and Robbie Hayes is here why
I've got a little bit of ground to make
up
I'm sorry guys but Robbie Hayes it's a
joke that they brought him in this late
Robbie lace he's missed four interviews
with me a few times and so that's how I
feel about Robbie and I interviewed
Wells Adams earlier this morning
shameless plug and he told me Robbie
also missed his flight to bachelor in
paradise so it already felt late to be
bringing him in and it felt really late
really really late to be bringing him in
right ahead of fantasy suites I don't
need this I don't need Robbie to take
Shu out I don't need Robbie different
Andy's here to find a connection I'll be
under your spell just call it up in de
okay
yeah Robbie takes you out because of a
lack of options Jordan did say quote I
feel like Robbie came here to saw my
bass often would to his Jordan I like it
so much I really do
we're just he come up with a stuff I
asked her about it at the Patel taping
and he said that he has a fax machine in
his head let's just send him messages
and spitting out spam and he's just
selected the best ones and I love that
he combined fax machine and spam it's
like he just combines eras of comedy and
observation and brings them all together
for us and we're gonna get two more of
my defense of Jordan Lee nobody can I
just can love Jordan
[Music]
anyway have you ever cheated
on anyone yes Robbie has asked about
whether or not he actually cheated on
Amanda Stanton and oh man that was weird
because in the news content train Boop
why did I just make a boat noise for a
train choo choo I don't know a man as
Stanton was arrested in Las Vegas well
I'm not an ATM I'm calm I don't want to
get into the legalities here guys I've
had a couple glasses of wine let's not
get dangerous
okay you don't know how I feel you
really don't know how I do Joe and
Kendall Joe and Kendall are on the verge
you guys Monday night's episode was full
of crazy breakups it felt out of nowhere
right well wells helped me understand
why he said that they cut filming short
by a week he's not sure if it was just
to keep people on their toes or because
producers just knew we've got a live he
cut a lot here we go way more than we
had last season the cast had to decide
real quick what they were doing so it
through some of the couples into a
spiral including Joe and Kendall
including to heaven and Astrid and wells
also said that Joe was kind of always
all-in on Kendall and she was always
kind of questioning it and this speech
from Joe
I've been falling in love with you since
day two I have never seen a truer moment
since the fictional film The Notebook
it's about security what is that
supposed to mean
money I don't mean that in a
condescending way I believe the notebook
I believe that everything is real and
that that's a documentary to me that in
a movie okay we're gonna have to work it
just every day but I want to do that
because I want you and I got pulled for
multiple dates and the first thing that
comes out of my mouth is joining Joe
speeds to Kendall about what she wants
about what she's ready for oh my god
anyways so Kendall breaks up with Joe
and for the next ten minutes I'm sure
you all have the reaction I did which is
why the would you do that Kendall
Kendall Kendall
[Music]
crystal and Chris you know crystal isn't
doing that voice anymore that she did an
re season but she is still impossible to
understand
[Music]
all right now everybody to finish out
money night's episode drink every time
there's a quick turnaround on a couple
because Chris Harrison came in wearing a
jacket even though it was really hot and
he said big decisions to be made today
you got to make a decision so you know
quick turnaround John and Olivia are
like we're into each other but we're out
of paradise because we don't wanna get
again quick turnaround Jordan and Cassie
the leave and the Xuan Robbie certainly
leave because that wasn't well was I
mean let's not what okay a quick and sad
turnaround I mentioned it before Kevin
is suddenly freaking out saying that he
doesn't know that he's ready for this he
needed more time he's at 80 percent not
a hundred he really needed that extra
week he was supposed to get producers
but it's okay because it on that because
our having else to ask
he looks like so sunburned like Warren
Houghton he goes he breaks up with her
and she leaves because he broke over
there and he's like don't leave me like
this
how was she supposed to leave I'm on a
stir inside there
that was a little over at the top Wells
and I decided that Kevin has some
Bachelor PTSD PTSD because he do if I
recently before that watched his ex
getting heated in front of him let's cut
the guys looks like I think Kevin's a
good guy okay episode two
Tuesday night now we have a proposals
and tell-all then too much content to
chew huh God vehicles honk okay analise
and Camille wake up together and Camille
says no it's gonna
but Annalise says she's excited for
Camille to propose Wow
but then Camille does say 14 he can't
live without her
[Music]
and then his proposal non-proposal
turned into was he reading from a
prompter I need to move at a pace that
is long-term for us did you guys see how
his eyes were like he was like I'm not
sure that I can do this I know you're
ready for engagement but I do like you I
need to move on a piece is long-term for
us but I am NOT ready but I love you so
yeah what was happening there it felt
that Camille had been scripted a speech
analyse and that he was looking off to
the side and reading and it make sense
to me because all season long I felt
like Camille does know a lot going on
behind you guys
anyway so but Annalise is okay you know
she's okay Elise is so hopeful and I
feel that that's her downfall even
though she was totally ready for a
proposal then she didn't get it she just
like I agree why I at least had a fair
self Annalise okay this is like the
first time I've ever felt all the way in
LA but we know the content of the rumors
that are overshadowing this so mm okay
I'm just gonna dress it now guys there's
a report that Jenna allegedly cheated on
Jordan I do have some reporting that it
is true I have some reporting that's the
reporting that I have more new comedies
yet line calm what do you think of the
Jenna and Jordan situation what do you
believe I want to know okay so Jordans
proposal
[Music]
[Applause]
I have never cried watching these shows
before I know that sounds crazy
I love these shows I'm just not much of
a crier at these shows but I cried
watching Jordans proposal
[Music]
that's how much I love Jordan it was the
first time I have ever can cried
watching these shows somebody asked me
if I cried watching Rachel and Peter
break up I didn't that was more shocking
this was I was happy tears I was emotion
I was crying yes and now we all are
where we are
that's life the way the skin cookie
crumbles that's the way the tequila goes
down match that's the way the Rose AMD's
last of all let's be honest we all knew
I would need more then chris is
proposing and Chris Chris Chris this is
not the time to with us
Pete is saying to Crystal quote I'm so
sorry but it would be unfair to the both
of us if I left here today holding your
hand
you knew this I need to leave you're
holding your heart but Chris shut them
don't mess with us like that
enough with your headband antics it's
been on too tight all season long just
propose okay and then the tell-all and
Chris Harrison introduces everyone I
thought it was very telling at the
tell-all who was out of the tell-all who
was not out to tell at the tell-all yeah
for example Kevin wasn't out in the
beginning where was Joe where was Astrid
where was Camille they re interesting
these are signs of drama to come guys
they hold people backstage they can hear
what's going on let me bring him out and
the bomb is dropped okay hey we didn't
invite Claire here did we cuz I'd like
to rewatch all that dope don't talk
about Claire man Sanwa versus Jordan
that fight is still so real I talked to
Jordan after the mint all about his
hatred for Benoit he really doesn't like
the guy I do wonder if they'll reconcile
now Jordan and David I'll get out but
who cares there's been too much content
drink every time there's been too much
content there has been too much at this
point I can't keep up that seems like 30
years ago doesn't it the Jordan and
David thing I mean I have aged since
then I've had five kids three two
horses and a boy toy since then I'm
exhausted
anyway Trust is something that I feel
like you don't have to hurt or something
that you have and until you lose it and
I lost it with her complete fault in my
own Kevin owns his stuff and I admire it
I see here how kevin is a 34 year old
man and he has had the BTS D but he's
owning it and he's saying I'm sorry and
I love this woman and per Instagram they
are together now and God do I want them
to make beautiful brunette babies they
soak really like Karen and Astron they
both just seem normal and grab it okay
what do you think about Kevin handled
the him and Astrid situation was the
break-up too much or were you okay with
how it was when he they got back
together Kendall and Joe Kendall goes to
see Joe in Chicago because she regretted
breaking up with him from just a minute
that she did although I asked her why
she didn't chase after him on the beach
in Mexico in that interviews uh but II
feel like calm and he's like I don't
know if I can get there but he got there
they're back together yay
I like the two of them and Joe says that
he loves Kendall and I like how gushy
they are over each other and cuddly and
it's cute I think you can always tell a
lot about whether a bachelor couple is
gonna last based on their body language
in the hot seats like they were all over
each other and happy to gush about each
other and I thought that that was cute
although it did concern me that joe says
he loved making Kendall mad I like when
she gets me in like the face making me
mad I didn't so much yeah don't do that
cute in the beginning that's so cute in
the end because it leads to the end I'm
not speaking from personal experience
but anyway I know some people and I
pulled some strings I have procured you
a spot on Dancing with the Stars
Chris Harrison I love that he paints Joe
going on Dancing with the Stars as if
he's single-handedly put it together
himself like Chris got on the phone and
he was like okay but I love the idea of
Joe going on Dancing with the Stars what
do you guys think I was totally shocked
by this because I don't remember the
last time it's ever a lead from the
bachelor world was not the one on
Dancing with the Stars like it's always
the lead yeah and it's only for the
bachelor reps like one time but Nick
vilely it's Sean Lowe lead Chris soules
lead so I was very surprised by this but
I like it I think it's a smart move on
the part of Dancing with the Stars to
bring Joe in to get some new viewers to
the show baby oh my god Camille breaks
up with Annalise I'm dead I died over
this you guys this was too much I've
risen because I'm here to support
Annalise oh my god as much as I thought
that Annalise was a little bit
delusional about her relationship with
Camille I do think he led her on a
little bit and the reactions to say it
all there's a woman in the audience who
can't even sit up straight anymore
Astrid forever the voice of reason says
this is up and there is a literal moment
of silence for this relationship
we should do some crickets there so
Annalise is blindsided she says Camille
just booked an air B&B for them stay the
week together yesterday yesterday an air
B&B yesterday and at this point in the
episode I started tweeting Airbnb
because give this woman a trip she said
she didn't have anywhere to stay he had
just booked this he had in no way
indicated to her that he was going to
break up with her on that stage
Camille's reasoning he claims he wanted
to be face to face with her and be a man
about it I want to be a man about it oh
really
out on the stage in front of everyone
okay I literally tried to break up with
you oh my god another reaction Tiye
going yes [ __ ] yes oh you're such I
don't want to when Annalise came back
out because she'd left the stage
distraught and shocked oh I watched he'd
say that forever and ever I can love TIA
I really do I forgot what a Spitfire she
is I love her Camille yeah I'm gonna say
goodbye to you we're gonna let you go
okay Chris says Camille bye
yes Chris Harrison get him out of there
you have the power to beget people on
Disney with the Stars and just fix them
from your stage when we come back then
Chris says that when we get back we're
going to find out where Jenna and Jordan
are at Wow oh that's depressed saying
it's too much content it's too much
context and it just all feels weird now
anyway also when Chris is like Chris
says to the women about Annalise okay
you guys can come up here and take care
of your girl you guys come take care of
your girl it's so weird it's like
everyone Gators though they were picking
her up off the street after a car
accident it was I mean not wrong but
weird
you were just so cold out there I
couldn't just go out there and pretend
that you know everything was perfect
between me then we see Camille and
Annalise backstage and they're talking
things out more and she's like well I
was trying I was willing to move to New
York and he says of course you are I
know you
yes of course you are very dark Camille
Barry hey there okay just break up with
the person okay
all right Jen and Jordan are on stage
and they are madly in love and god this
is rough was this super painful for you
guys to watch it was painful for me was
it hard for you
they'd hurt for me okay and then Jordan
has Chris Harrison to officiate their
wedding on June 9th I would be honored
at the time of the publication of this
video we were under the understanding
that Jordan and Jenna are still together
but I don't know how much things will
change so that DT I'm I'm back on for
the later hi guys I'm here in the Edit
Bay with JC hi babe and we are trying to
finish roses and rose a for you but I've
also been doing tons of reporting all
day and finding out what's going on with
Jenna and Jordan and you've seen it on
et online.com they've broken up go there
for the lady
and what's my reaction all that I want
to say is that I love Jordan I've loved
him since day one and I support Jordan
and I think Jenna's figuring her stuff
out but here for Jordan hear from both
really because it's a confusing time
Jessie what's your reaction so tired
so tired we're just tired we love you
guys what a season Wow
send us your thoughts are you upset they
broke up are you shocked what do you
think who do you believe love you bye
okay then Chris and crystal Chris is
crying I don't know why
and then we see Colton just for a minute
in silence to remind us that you know he
didn't say one word of this tell-all but
he's our new bachelor everybody
jaesi always dresses to the nines and he
is in a suit today just like the men at
the tell-all were in suits so as a
special treat he is going to give his
impressions of the standout man from the
towel
[Music]
Chris I'm just really happy so honey you
know I love you so much I know you're
ready for engagement I love you so much
that's why I waited to be in front of
national television to break up with you
I think I might not be the guy for you
welcome back everybody so I've made a
few calls and you know how powerful I am
procured you a spot everyone's on
Dancing with the Stars
you're on Dancing with the Stars you're
on Dancing with the Stars oh my gosh you
guys what a season what a season this is
I think the best season of bachelor in
paradise we have ever had I really do
there was so much drama so much real
love the women came to play and they did
we had great men like Jordan and Jo who
were focused on being all about their
women
we had the Colton tears we had the TA
yes [ __ ] yes moment like oh my god it
was iconic was this your favorite season
of bachelor in paradise ever let me know
and on that note we have to come upon a
gap the gap between bachelor and
Paradise and The Bachelor or JC and I
won't see you guys as much it's really
hard that's really sad I'm trying to
come up with the solution please leave
me your suggestions what would you would
you like anything from us in the
meantime should we do something else
should we recap another show should we
just do videos like about bachelor news
once a week in this insane voice with
this insane amount of wine and just talk
about the news with you guys I want to
know what you want from me because I am
here to serve you and myself
I love you so much I love hearing from
you as always
bye
[Music]